you're making the free stuff at scale
to hit a lot of people
and then the people who do have money to
take it deeper with you are the ones who
are going to pay you to do your thing I
wanted to be in charge of my life and
and live life on my own terms we need to
start a coaching business yeah
I love the background yeah it's a tree
in my backyard I decided to put this one
up so I felt like it would be a nice
background for this life
you know I just posted on uh on Twitter
let me read this out just five minutes
outside with some sun on your face might
give you the perspective shift you need
right now yeah that's awesome man I just
want to say thank you for everything I
always um I always speak to to my wife
and a lot of people about you and about
what movement makers is and I let them
know the reason why I joined the group I
remember I was in um doing the real
success Summit and I think you did a
training on YouTube and I saw your
perspective on life and how you said the
main thing that got me was to help
someone who was once who was feeling
what you once felt the greatest pain
right and and showing them to believe
and finding their purpose and that's
what really drew me drew me to uh
movement makers and that's what I've
been doing with the sofa lifting Brad
and everything so I guess today what I
wanted to talk about too is um how does
someone because I know Evan tinselman
also had this this dilemma of we do help
people we help people for free we don't
we're not doing it actually for for a
pay or for a compensation but when you
want to make a living of it how can you
do that without kind of guilting
yourself
well it's recognizing that some people
want more access right and it's okay to
charge people for more access so the
beginning I mean I do a lot for free
yeah
I do a ton for free I mean I mean the
videos are all free the YouTube channel
is all free
um every night I'm doing Instagram like
last night yesterday was such a long day
and writing my new book and like also
just crazy busy and then at you know
it's 11 something at night and I'm
sitting on my back patio just dead tired
answering people's questions from
Instagram and putting it to my stories
because you know maybe in answering
those 10 questions it might be the
perspective shift that somebody needs
right like you never know yeah yeah and
um
and an analogy I I thought of that too I
thought of it um because I spoke to some
people about it uh privately and we
think about it it's like um when I was
in Community College there was a math
lab there right and and there was a math
lab and it was free of course it was
actually it was uh accessible to all the
students and there were about there'll
be about 50 or 60 students at a time in
that math lab maybe about seven eight
tutors and they would answer your
questions but it was like it was kind of
like a quick
um two-minute answer like okay they
would help you with this but they
wouldn't really be able to go over it
with you and then I was in some student
club that
they they had private tutors for us now
the private tutor which the the student
Club paid for was able to give you that
one-on-one access you know that
one-on-one and because of that private
tutor I was able to pass that stats
statistics class and I compared it as an
analogy like when you're paying for
someone it's kind of like now they're
gonna dedicate this time strictly to you
and in that time frame that you're
paying for and it's going to be a
one-on-one and also it takes away time
from their personal life right so that's
the way I was seeing it similar okay but
okay so so you have the answer yeah yeah
that's the thing so what's the hold up
uh I think that and sometimes I get
really um stuck because there's these
all these populations I want to help you
know um I I battled addiction before I
came from you know poverty foster care
says my grandparents I actually adopted
my siblings and I said I was working
with Fosters I was working with homeless
youth I've worked with those who are
forming incarcerated uh drug addicted
and I was like I want to help all those
but I know also like with Dean graciosi
what they say too is about narrowing
down your dot but you were talking about
your Niche so I'm thinking do I start
with just one and then expand later or
uh how would I do it or do I try to um
do something that kind of reaches out to
all of them
inside of it
we're talking about making money from
our from our purpose uh all of those
people still have money like not
everybody will have most people won't
have money right like most people who
are addicts won't have money because
they spend all their money on you know
their addiction and hopefully trying to
get help but there's there's still some
people who you know I know some of them
who have
a lot of money and are addicts like it's
when you're an addict and you have money
it's even worse because now you doesn't
mean limiting you got access you got
money you can and um Joe pollach who's a
good friend uh he used to be an addict
and he does a lot of work with addicts
helping them because once you have money
and you're an addict that's a very
dangerous combination
um so a lot of people you want help
people go to prison like most of them
don't have money but some of them do you
know and so it's like you're you're
making the free stuff at scale
to hit a lot of people
and then the people who do have money to
take it deeper with you are the ones who
are going to pay you to do your thing
who do you who do you love working with
the most like if you're looking at
people in prison or people on drugs or
you look at all your all the people who
you like helping what's the common
element between them
and that's what I was thinking of the
other day I think the common element has
to do with like um it's kind of what
when I saw one of your videos where
you're talking about like the greatest
pain like it's like a past pain that
people can't get past like they can't
get past a pain and they're bringing
that into the present which is then kind
of um putting a barrier to the Future
because they don't know how to let go of
that so that's the thing me and Rosie
talk about sometimes too is about
healing and you know forgiveness and and
how to let go of that and how that is
strictly for the person who who is in
pain it's not so much A lot of people
think forgiveness has to do with well
well we're gonna go now shake hands have
a beer and become best friends again it
doesn't really have to do with that you
don't have it you don't have to hang out
with the person again it's just freeing
yourself from that burden so I think a
lot of it has to do with people holding
on to something because I did a poll
once and a lot of people answered like
what was holding back and it was about
letting go of things you know so I think
that's one of the common elements for
all of them is that all of them have
some type of past that they can't let go
of so you you've been an addict yeah I
was I was uh I used to drink heavily for
like for 10 probably about 10 years from
my teenage years to my mid-20s
um after my best friend and my mother
passed away they passed away like in a
two-month span and I remember after I
just started drinking to kind of numb it
and then it became an addiction and it
became pretty strong um and were you
were you incarcerated no I wasn't
incarcerated but I worked a lot and and
the area I grew up with it was a lot of
you know gang violence
um there was drugs it was low income you
could call it the hood the ghetto
whatever and a lot of those
um friends I had a lot of the friends I
had and a lot of people that I
associated with I talked to them they
were good at heart like they like they
were cool people but they just got
caught up with the with the wrong
environment and actually one of one of
my friends who's Hollywood Hollywood
producer Scott Button he's very
dedicated to that population on helping
him get a second chance in life so
that's why I have uh empathy towards
them too you know and as like you said
so for that population I've always been
able to you know hey give resources or
help them in some way because of course
they don't have money and then the other
people that can't let go
or maybe other people that are trying to
get trained on how to help those people
as well because I've had
um friends and colleagues who started
working with the homeless population
ask me questions and stuff maybe those
are people that I also could uh reach
out to in a different level what do you
love doing the most is it speaking is it
coaching is it talking to people
one-on-one like what do you what could
you get lost in
can I get lost in
um yeah I think it would be
I could choose between maybe speaking
one-on-one or speaking like as an
audience um when when I um because I've
I've also done some public some some
workshops before when I was working at a
college I did some workshops with a
friend that were like personal
development build healthy relationships
empowerment
and speaking in front of audiences
that's always been something that that I
love too
um I was very frightened at first with
public speaking but I got over it as the
more I did it and speaking one-on-one I
think also helps so that's why I'm
thinking like I've never done the I've
actually done like kind of coaching
because I was a mentor advisor to Foster
Youth and college students
um but I guess never coaching as a
business I've I've never
um approached it that way so I think
um this just speaking in general to
someone and just just helping them and
being there with them being present with
them is something that really uh
resonates with me how much of your
community is part of
what you're trying to elevate so to make
that a little more clear I mean I love
helping entrepreneurs that's my
community right so I'm I'm physically in
Toronto I love Toronto uh it's my home
it's amazing I don't have as much like
City Pride that I need to help Toronto
blow up or I need to help like my
neighborhood in Toronto blow up I'm
trying to help the world right how much
how much for you it's okay so it's not
as much about like your local community
or
it's everyone um it's just like I know
I'm not trying to broaden out where it's
like but like just like you I'm trying
to I think I'm just trying to help as
many people going through that problem
of
because I've seen a lot of people that
and I know a lot of people that have
money they have money they have
everything a person could want but
they're bitter and they're kind of
miserable inside because they can't let
go of something so I think my thing is
probably letting go and just and living
fully in the present where it's kind of
like healing you know healing from
whatever it was that could be trauma
whatever is pain you want to call it
that's keeping them back and keeping
them for living in the present because
um I feel that's that's the thing that I
see with a lot of people so that's kind
of and that that goes to anyone you know
it could be someone I've met people on
here that are from uh that have told
that have reached out to me and told me
they like my content and there's people
from Australia England and other places
so it's open to everyone
okay so the people who you know who have
money let's stick with these people like
however many that is 10 people five
people 20 people what would they pay you
to do
um I've spoken to someone before and I
think a lot of them would it'd probably
be like one-on-one kind of uh one-on-one
uh coaching someone that's there what
you pretty much like what you do for us
with Movie Makers you know someone
that's there and I think a lot of times
it's like what a lot of people say when
you don't pay you don't pay attention
and sometimes pain and having someone
right there gives you some form of
accountability too so I think that's
what they need they need accountability
and they need someone to kind of be
there and sometimes it's kind of like
hand holding in the beginning so that
they could get to where they want to be
and how many of these people do you know
who you think might be able to afford
that
ah
um
I would say
from the top of my head maybe a few
dozen already uh from what I yeah like
30 20.
000 is 12. 30 40 people okay so you know
30 40 people who have money
maybe not like the rich or the rich but
they've got money and they're struggling
and they could use they could afford
your help so what's what's preventing
you from reaching out and saying hey
I've got a coaching service
um I think the because I do have
something set up with uh Dean and Tony's
like mastermind.com I think it's it's so
overthinking of like oh I need a
structure like this and I need to do it
perfectly and I do because I know
Perfection leads for me the way I say it
is perfection leads to procrastination
and I think um what I just need to do is
just just get it out there because a lot
of them already have reached out to me
and they know what I'm about and I've
been doing it here on here for two hours
they reached out to you for what they've
reached out to me in ways you're saying
like to continue doing what I'm doing
what I do really helps them and and it
it um it is really sometimes there's
days where they'll watch something that
I did or or even you know if I message
and I try to get them through something
that that makes a difference you know
that makes a difference from where they
were going to have a crappy day and and
now they feel like they could tackle the
day and they they feel that they could
tackle things with with the more
optimistic mindset so um
just simple things like that tells me
that it's reaching people
we need to start a coaching business
yeah
[Laughter]
this is it this is this is a start and
it's nice to have you know Dean and Tony
are awesome and you know the
mastermind.com plan is more it's not
about coaching it's more about creating
you know the circles and and the
the structure but honestly I think the
best coaches
are fluid
where
if you're looking at this like we're
doing this this is meta right now right
we're coming on obviously I know who you
are it's not like we're meeting for the
I mean I guess like maybe first time
kind of doing like one-on-one kind of
stuff but
um I don't need you to send me a huge
agenda of what we're going to talk about
today and I also don't need to have to
put you into
a certain template because we're gonna
we're gonna Bob and weave depending on
what you actually need yeah and that's
exactly why I kind of ventured off on my
own too because
um in the mental health field you know I
was training in mental health therapy uh
for for over like about a year or so
over a year and I was doing mental
health therapy with um children
adolescence you know I had some of my
clients were as young as like three and
the reason why I kind of ventured off of
my own the pandemic even though it was a
big impact on me and my family
financially my wife took in a lot of or
took on like the finances and everything
she already had her career going with me
I was barely graduating it hit me hard
so the job I had lined up they they kind
of uh decided they weren't going to go
with the extending the offer because of
covert they closed some of the buildings
out
um when I was doing when I was working
that I saw that a lot of it's like
it just for me it didn't feel original
because you kind of have to go like you
said I had to go off a script you got to
go this way ask them this way do this
and you had to use a certain approach
that they wanted let's say like
cognitive behavior therapy whatever and
my original way of connecting and always
building Rapport and and connections
with people and helping them
it's like I couldn't apply it so I was
limited and that's the reason why too
that I wanted to do my own thing because
where I'm not limited to what someone
tells me you can't do this you could do
this you can't do that and the main
thing too is I wanted to be in charge of
my life and and live life on my own
terms own my own time where someone
doesn't have to do and I think that's
the dream for every entrepreneur too is
you live life in your own term you have
CBT cool you've got other tools and
Technologies and as you learn from
different people too you can continue to
apply those but what a great coach does
is take the best tool at the moment that
the client needs right now
so it's not that everybody has to go
through this exact same process that
that's a course that's Group Training
that's not
that's not coaching like it's it the
best coaching is when you can if you're
doing one-on-one coaching you're
listening to see where they're at and
what they need and you're giving them
the exact thing they need right now yeah
right like if you think about movement
makers that's group coaching and it's
still always based off of what you guys
want right there's always the poll every
what do you want everyone to talk about
because I don't need to talk about
anything I want to talk about what you
guys want to talk about what do you need
help with the most you vote that's what
I make content on but it's still group
coaching based off of what you guys are
asking uh where when it's one-on-one the
best coaches you just show up and say
hey how can I help and you know enough
from different things people that
actually give them the direct advice and
perspective shift that they they need
yeah
what's your next like Revenue goal like
where do you need to be
um
I've been writing it down and
I I don't know like right now um
even though I do all this like no no one
would ever know like even though I do
all this like let's say I'm in a
financial struggling no one ever no
because I'm still extending um my help
and everything to everyone because
sometimes I feel like ah I don't want it
to feel like
um now they're thinking like okay now
it's about sales now it's about this now
it's about it's not really about that
the way I see it the way I see it is
like um I've said this to people that I
I know um personally I told them why
well it's like this even though you love
the job let's say a lot of people go to
a school for a career that they love
like they've specifically picked that
career that that curriculum that
discipline it's like you your job saying
we know you love this we know you do it
from your heart so we decided we're not
going to pay anymore they're going to be
like what though you know so okay but
like what do you need to to pay the
bills and you're not off buying Lambos
but you're like you're you're paying
your bills you're not like barely
surviving but you're you're actually
paying the bills and able to continue
doing what you love like what's that
first number that you need to hit
I think just to um start off I I wrote a
goal down a number I kept seeing a
number and I wrote it down so I was I
wrote down the the number 7 800 like to
start off like it could be less than
that and it'll be fine but what is that
a month or it's just some stuff just to
help with with my wife because my wife
my wife is um
nurse practitioner actually she just got
her doctorate so she she had her career
going and she she works very hard and
you know she's um she's very hard work
ethic so she's it's it's but a lot of it
comes
um comes tumbling down on her sometimes
and you know I'm trying my best I do
little side things to try to help her
out to where we both can be comfortable
with the income whereas it's not like
all right this time the mortgage is
gonna be uh it's gonna be tough or this
time uh the the car payment or whatever
it is yeah it says you're unable to join
wow okay answer this question then the 7
800 that you need what is that is that
is that a total number is that a monthly
number
like where do we need to be at per month
that it's it starts to ease things for
you that that again you're not off
buying Lambos but it it makes it like
hey this is happening the phone the
iPhone shut down because of the sun I
hear you
I'll break down your model just give me
the number that what do you need to be
at a month so we said 70 100 I wasn't
clear on what is that your monthly
number or is that a total number is that
a a yearly number what is that every two
months six months what what is that 7
800 or just tell me where you need to be
monthly and then we'll run some numbers
and we'll we'll get you going to be
completely comfortable would be 7 800 to
10 000 since my wife's income combined
would make us stress-free monthly okay
700 a month so here's what we do so
he has 30 or 40 people who he knows who
have reached out to him who have money
who could potentially afford his
Services uh we need to start a coaching
business
this is the starting point to figure out
what is actually working when you're
talking to people as well as making some
money and whether that means your wife
quits your job or if she's doing it
because she still loves it or she scales
back hours whatever
let's start at 100 bucks an hour okay
let's see you're charging 100 bucks an
hour that's not a crazy number right
when I'm looking at
um
Drew or like people that I'm investing
in internally we want to be 500 an hour
right so like how do we start making 500
plus an hour on the time that you're
you're investing into things but let's
start at 100 bucks 100 bucks an hour is
achievable right uh
you sell a weekly coaching program
so you're going to start with the 40
people that you know
and you're gonna say I I'm starting a
new service it's a weekly coaching
program with me for one hour every week
to help you let go of the past to help
you with accountability to help you with
all the things that that you're saying
that they need help with right
100 bucks an hour
52 weeks right an hour a week every week
and you can batch them you can put them
all on maybe not all in one day but you
can have like two days of coaching three
days off or whatever whatever makes
sense but you're going to start the
Outreach to those people
okay 100 bucks an hour
for a weekly coaching call one hour with
you
okay so let's run some math so you got
100 bucks an hour
52 weeks that's 5200 bucks per person
per year right
this is awesome I appreciate it okay
this is what we're gonna do so it's 5200
bucks a year if you want to sell it at
five thousand dollars a year for an hour
with you every week plus you can have
access on the email and whatever
afterwards right so 52
5200 bucks a year
that means if we want to be making
let's see so we get
we want to be at
7 800 a month
let's do this let's do some math here
you need 18 people
18 people
signing up for 100 bucks an hour
for a yearly don't sell it as like an
hour whenever you need me no no we're
booking this in it's like you're hiring
a trainer your trainer comes and trains
you you're you're their accountability
you're their trainer but for for mindset
to help them get past the thing that
they were struggling with
100 bucks an hour
once once a week for an hour
18 people
you get 18 people
that's giving you 90 93 600 a year
you're almost at 100K that's 700 a month
that's your game plan so if you know 40
people your goal is now to reach out to
them
message them let them know what you
don't customize not like some Mass
emailed everybody
and say I'm starting a new coaching
business to help you all the things you
said
break free from the past have
accountability live a happy life like
whatever the big things are that you
want to help them with wow that's great
to sell for lifting we but this is now
the work like you have to reach out to
them you know it's valuable you know
what's going to have an impact
it's five thousand dollars a year and
that's a that's still a deal right like
the whole point of this is we're trying
to get you to the point where we're
taking the stress and burden away from
you financially so that you can live
your life and your wife is not stressed
out as well right this is not
um
this is not hey how are we building a 10
million dollar company yet yeah we'll
get there like step one is getting past
survival and living stress free right so
18 people
at 100 bucks an hour we're going to
reach out to the 40 people that we know
and tell them you're launching this
program he says I'm going to make the
list of the people to reach out and
start putting the numbers together
so make your list of your 40 people look
at everybody who's messaged you who's
reached out to you
say it I'm starting a new coaching
program I love to talk to you about it
get on a call with them talk them
through what you're thinking
you get me
every week at the same time for an hour
to hold you accountable to help you
break free from all your your past
trauma to help you stay consistent on
the goals that you set for yourself just
like you might hire a personal trainer
this is a personal trainer for your
mindset
five thousand dollars a year
me every week for an hour
18 people
that's you working you know that's 18
hours a week
18 hours a week you have almost a
six-figure income
and you still have time to do your
videos and Outreach and everything else
and once we hit that number now we start
increasing our prices right so you hit
your number you hit your seven eight
hundred cool now now we're at we're
doing work that we love like coaching
people
for 18 hours a week is stuff that we
love right hopefully otherwise we're not
doing it you're doing work that you love
we're hitting our Baseline so that we're
not stressed out about you know paying
bills and where the next meal is coming
from
and now we start increasing our prices
so for the next people let's just saying
that was perfectly put together this
definitely broke a barrier cool man
then after that after 18 like 18 gets us
towards Seventeen hundred dollars a
month cool after 18 so 19 20 21 right
now we're charging 150 bucks a month now
we're charging 200 bucks like an hour
sorry not a month an hour
you go from 100 to 150 to 200 to 250
right like you just keep increasing the
prices and and then it becomes a how
much time do you want to spend like
trading you're trading your time for
money which is cool and it's fun I mean
you're trading your time for money doing
something you love as opposed to
something you hate working a job for
somebody else right cool
now we start to scale up the the level
of people that we're talking to so now
you know as you move to the 200 an hour
maybe we're dropping some of the 100 an
hour people like maybe they don't
continue maybe they you know maybe pass
it on to somebody else but we're
spending we're starting to work with
more ideal clients who can pay us more
because if you got 200 bucks an hour
then you only need nine people
right like 200 an hour
once a week coaching for nine people
gets you your 94 000 business which is
700 bucks a month
200 bucks an hour times nine people
I mean if you feel comfortable you can
even just start there
it's just a mad group you already have
this is not everybody right like most of
your audience won't be able to do this
and 100 200 bucks an hour for people who
have money is not it's not a ton of
money if you think about even in your
own business when you hire a lawyer when
you hire an accountant when you're
hiring professionals it's costing you
more than 100 bucks an hour to hire a
lawyer
and you're going to do you know probably
a lot more good a lot more help than
somebody's lawyer no no disrespect to
lawyers out there
so yes it's like 100 100 bucks an hour
is 18 people 200 bucks an hour is nine
people and you've hit your financial
goal
then we start charging more then we can
launch Books then we can launch paid
speaking then we can launch courses then
we can launch everything else but it's
like it's you you already have access to
some of these people right it's not like
you've got a list of a million people
who can afford you but you've got 40.
and now it's you getting over the
discomfort of doing the Outreach and
letting people know that you have this
program
Soulful lesson says I was making the
math harder than I thought I continue to
help those with no money for free on my
page and charge others for one-on-one I
was overthinking it awesome I mean I
hope this is the perspective shift that
that you needed
we tend to overthink things but it's
like behind it is the fear to do the
Outreach so what's the fear to reach out
to the 40 people to say I want to coach
you for one hour per week for the next
year and it's going to cost either five
thousand 100 bucks an hour or 200 bucks
an hour and and not just like let's do
this week and and see you sell the whole
year in advance
right they can even pay me in advance
like sell the whole year in advance
now you have ninety four thousand
dollars in your pocket right now
right as opposed to like waiting for it
to come out and what's he saying this
helped me a lot Evan thanks my friend we
need to chat again soon yeah and I mean
we've got just enough out of you before
the phone died so it's great it's like
what's that number just enough we at
least enough to make it happen so that's
great I'm glad that we could do this
everything you're doing to help the
people
who are paying you 100 200 bucks an hour
and then 300 and 400 and 500 whatever
right like when there's no we're not
limiting how high you can go it's just
let's get to Baseline but everything
you're doing to help them is also the
content that you can make and you can do
for free
right like uh this is this is something
that I would get paid to talk to people
to do and we're doing it for free over
Instagram live and hopefully everybody
watching can learn from it as well so
you can still share the information and
still do more coaching I'm asking for
for nine to 18 hours a week of coaching
to help you get to your financial goal
you've got more than 9 to 18 hours a
week to to live your your life and run
your dream business so what are you
doing in the other time it could be
doing Instagram lives it could be a
coaching it could be working on content
could be making your videos uh it could
be you know posting content Instagram
Tick Tock YouTube Etc like you still
have time during the week to do other
stuff
but it's just getting over that hurdle
of I'm going to launch a coaching
program I already haven't you already
have enough value to help these people
you know you do and it's worth easily
100 bucks an hour
and just feeling that
more Swagger and not let egotistical
Swagger
it's like the value ladder correct you
still give value for free but charges
the latter goes higher yeah you can
think of it like that like your free
offering is the content and then people
pay for access to you and that's the
only this is where people over
complicate things too like all you need
is to get that done because that's why I
asked you what what is your number if
it's seven eight hundred bucks a month
cool let's get you to that number before
you're worried about people then think
oh well I'm gonna make a thousand bucks
a month from my book and two thousand
bucks a month for my course and you're
trying to do not that you're doing it
because we didn't die that deep but
people often overthink it and try to
launch a million things to get to that
number
and they and they're thinking Beyond
like how do I build my Million Dollar
business like let's get you making money
first
if that number reduces a lot of stress
for you and your wife and usually the
the momentum to keep going cool let's
get to that number first and it still
gives you the time to work on the other
stuff that you want to work on to build
your business
and if you love coaching it's the
easiest place to start as opposed to
writing a book or making courses
um and all the other stuff that gives
you more scale and leverage but takes a
lot longer to create
and by the way your courses and books
everything else your speeches will all
be better the more coaching you do
because you've actually interact with
people who are paying you right I
actually did that last night he says I
was writing all the numbers for
different Outlets where I should folk
when I should focus on this yeah like
just use it and it's just a matter of
we're not we're not saying no to all
those other things
it's just let's let's there's a sequence
let's stick to the sequence let's get
you your number 1700 or 10 10 000
whatever a month let's get there
and then we can worry about adding
everything else out because you're
you're being a much better spot to
create
if you've gotten some of those financial
issues taken care of for you
it makes sense we're often so focused on
scale and we're thinking about a
thousand different passive income
streams like get to the number that you
need first through something active that
you actually like doing right like if
you didn't like coaching then that's
this is not a good this is not a good
model
right let's find something else but if
he actually likes talking to people and
coaching then this is the path
so
it's it's clarity now we've got Clarity
since I see this live with something
many people were struggling with I'm
glad this topic helped everyone yeah and
this is what you can do too right I mean
it doesn't mean you stop helping for
free
but it's clear again Direction
all you need to focus on is getting your
7 800 a month coaching business set up
that's the number one priority of things
that you're gonna sell and then two of
the mental unwinding of I'm going to
reach out to people and let them know
that this exists that I can bring value
that my time is worth
a hundred two hundred dollars an hour to
these people and I'm gonna charge that
because I want I want and if you're not
even doing it for you think of it for
them think of it for your wife they give
the life that you're trying to build
like whenever you're stuck in in limited
thinking and you need more courage think
about who you're doing it for so it's
not just you because when it's just you
we tend to play small but if it's like
I'm doing this for my for my wife
because she's going to work every day
and she's stressing out and I want her
not to stress out as much
I'm I'm saying that and I want to do
more for my like Nina works in the
company but if that was me like it just
brings an extra gear that I have to go
do it now right or if like you think
about the people like that you're
helping and they're struggling and they
need guidance and there's nobody there
like you're doing it for them when you
can flip the service it gives you a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
show up than you would do otherwise for
yourself for my family my wife and two
toddlers yeah so like keep them in mind
have a picture uh you know in front of
you or just visualize them as you're
making your list like that's your
homework for today is make that list of
people
that you're going to reach out to maybe
it's not 40 maybe it's 100. you know and
the worst is somebody says hey I can't
do that right now or if somebody says
hey I can't afford that or hey I'm not
interested like that's the worst that
happens
but if you reach out if you take your 40
list and you turn it to 100 can we get
18 people who will pay you 100 bucks a
month or nine people who are pay you 200
sorry a week for an hour right 18 people
at 100 bucks an hour or nine people at
200 bucks an hour
if you meet a list of 100 people
you can do that it's like it now becomes
like that's almost easy now if you're
operating from that zone of I'm here for
my wife for my toddlers I'm building
this life up myself right like this is
important to me if you're operating from
that framework that's where we need to
be mindset wise
because if you're thinking oh yeah you
know really hire me I don't know I don't
know if I'm bringing up value to them
do I use a website a personal payment
option just do PayPal easy
I mean Jeremy and Drew and Bo we've all
built mid six figure businesses together
they have no website
they have no they have an email they
have an email and it's a PayPal link
that we send them there's no website go
look up Jeremy go look up Drew go look
up Bo there's no website you don't need
to get fancy with it these are people
who already know you
PayPal gotta send them a link
five thousand bucks a year for coaching
one hour a week with me
and if you're feeling extra bold ten
thousand bucks a year one hour a week
with me
and I'll help you achieve your goals and
I'll help you unlock the past because
that's worth it to them
and now you've got that 93 600 sitting
in your bank account up front
makes a huge difference
now you got to do the work man do the
work hold your wife in your head go give
her a hug go give your kids you know a
kiss on the forehead and and go build
that list and go to the Outreach like
you got tons of time left today to build
that list and start doing the Outreach
hey and there she is it's so nice to see
your face how you doing I'm great how
are you I'm great I've met right now
this is the first time we're actually
connecting kind of I guess we're not in
person but close enough we have the same
publisher that we share Cara Polson and
uh I saw you on her stories and I just
love the energy and the vibe and
um there's just a little voice that said
you know what you should reach out and
and do an IG live together I'm gonna ask
her and you said yes and so here we are
we're making it happen well the answer
to how is yes so I just said yes and I I
didn't even know really what I was
saying yes to but it's just so great to
to talk to you in person as I've
listened to your books on my Audible and
watched you with Kira and you wrote a
book in less than a week
just huge huge props to you and all that
you're doing and the difference that you
make for so many people
I love it so as I was watching your
story since before we went live and you
said you did something difficult this
morning that that prepped you for this
what was that difficult thing
uh a cold Plunge
okay have you done a cold plunge before
I've done a cold plunge yet so my
husband loves the cold plunge and he's
created a sanctuary on the side of our
house that has an outdoor shower and a
sauna and a cold plunge and every
morning I go out there and I say the
hard things that I'm about to do in my
life and my projects my books coaching
all of those things and then I'm like
okay if I can get in this then I can do
all of those hard things because it is
really hard to take the step into the
freezer is that a daily thing that you
do I'm trying to make it a daily thing
as often as possible yeah I love that
that was a setup for this and teaching
yourself you do hard things you know
first thing in the morning we didn't
really have an agenda for this it was
just more like I reach out and I thought
we could do an ID live together what
where does your heart take you would you
rather talk about your book and what
you're doing in healing through
relationships or is there something that
I can help you with where you are in
your journey that would be of value for
you either way where is your heart
taking you oh wow that is like a hard
Split Decision
uh can we do a little of both
okay cool
um okay well let's start with how I can
help what I mean where are you at what's
if you had to ask a question or two what
um what feedback could I could I give
um I feel like I'm at this tipping point
where like I have a few coaching clients
I'm in the in the middle of
um publishing these three books one uh
with my husband that I have been writing
for like eight years about our marriage
divorce and remarriage to each other
and um and then as I was writing that
book this collaboration book with Kira
came up where that's like creating some
momentum and then I have a children's
book that's kind of about my inner child
and and my uh upbringing so I feel like
I'm at this Tipping Point where I'm
gaining momentum on Instagram I'm
sharing my stories
but I also feel a little bit
like I don't know what else to do I
don't know where else to go
in order to do what what's the goal
building resiliency even though you've
had really hard things
and ultimately is it
your business model is going to be the
book or programs or coaches or
consulting or what what's the what's the
business ultimately going to be
good question
um it's going to be coaching
and I have a couple of digital courses
already and then these books and you
know ultimately I really love I'm a born
performer I've been singing my entire
life I love being on a stage
um I would love to speak
so that that is my personal goal I just
want to like be out there and be with
people and be on a stage maybe speak and
sing that would be really great
speak and sing Okay cool so listen
whatever you want to make money doing
the best content to make is show me the
process of you doing it
so
take all of those things that you love
and now think how can I show people how
I do this so if singing is going to be a
big part of what you want to do then
having regular singing content like
random singing content if coaching's
what you want to do and sell then show
me you coaching
like okay like live sessions with people
like this yeah this is like this if I
wanted to sell coaching this would be a
great example you know it's like I'm
this is it I mean I didn't even didn't
know what we were going to do when we
went live she's like hey just show up
and we'll see what happens but this is a
great example of coaching uh and so if
it's about your book is about
relationships right healing through a
broken relationship yeah so you have
people come on who are dealing with
their relationship that they feel is
broken and they need some feedback and
guidance and help and care and love and
your
you know why I I fell in love with your
Vibe and mean like again I didn't know
you've never met you before before that
but your your
just the way you sink into your heart in
the care and the energy is just really
calming and peaceful and loving and I
could see you
I could see you if you're doing coaching
sessions where people would open
themselves up to you where they haven't
told anybody else the things that they
might tell you
okay I don't know if you've already
experienced that with friends or family
or other people you know in your life
but where you just create a safe space
for people to share things that they are
afraid to admit to anybody else yeah
which makes a great coach because it's
like great listening but then also being
able to give great advice and so some
people uh will not want to be public
you know some people may not want to be
coached on an Instagram video right like
a YouTube video and that's cool you
don't need everybody to say yes
um but
the fact that you're an author doesn't
mean you're going to be a great coach
true but you are but like people don't
know that right like if the fact that
you wrote a book doesn't mean that
people will think I want to hire her as
my coach
so the best way to get coaching clients
is to show me you coaching the best way
to get Book Sales is just show me you
with the book and teaching lessons from
the book the best way to get more
speaking gigs is to show me you speaking
so you start booking speaking gigs you
know even for free like go speak at your
local YMCA or library or high school or
tedx talk like it doesn't have to be
some giant
you know Mel Robbins on stage in front
of an arena full of people
just the fact that you are speaking
makes me think oh she's a speaker I
might hire her to come and speak at my
next event
and so it's like the more you can have
fun in doing the content and the more
that it actually
in showing the process leads to
a business result that then like the
ultimate goal is impact right it's like
how do I reach more people and if you
turn it into a business and you can
reach more people right if it's like you
part-time on the side doing it then we
don't want it to take another eight
years to like get the next thing out
right right but if you're making money
doing it then you can have a team then
you can invest more in people then you
can reach a lot more people with your
message and your content yeah that makes
so much sense it seems like as you say
it it's so logical okay
why does that not make sense and why
does that not come into my mind and can
I just say the reason it doesn't come
into my mind to begin with is because I
get stuck on the trajectory of where I'm
going and it feels so far away like I
don't know how I'm gonna get there and
then I get stopped
so stop steps like you're talking about
yeah yeah so like how many people how
many people follow you on Instagram
right now
I think I'm at 1400. Perfect the first
1400 is the hardest fourteen hundred so
you're already on your way you got you
got the momentum
um to my new book coming out uh the way
to do it is to message the people who
are following you and say you're going
to start a new show
once a day or once a week or whatever
you know feels right for you
of coaching and do they want to be your
guest were you going to coach them for
free
where normally they would have to hire
you to do coaching but here it's free
coaching but it's going to be public and
hopefully in that person's story other
people can learn from them as well and
some people will say no I don't want it
to be public they might ask you can I
hire you though to be my coach you know
now all of a sudden now we have a
coaching like how are you actually
coaching people now and getting paid to
do it yeah perfect so it's a good
lead-in right that you can offer them
the free one on your Instagram but if
they they say no they might want to just
hire you to be their coach anyway
yeah and then you'll get some people who
say yes and then that's how you start
your show and the Beautiful Thing with
that is you just have to show up
you don't need to prepare like if you're
thinking about making an Instagram video
or YouTube video there's a lot of work
to prepare in script and like what am I
gonna you know we're coaching you just
show up you say hey Susan welcome how
can I help what's on your mind what's in
your heart
and shares and then you go help her
um and it's actually fun because you
feel like what you're doing matters and
helps and is having an impact and maybe
Susan ends up
you know wanting to work with you and
hire you to be her coach cool but if not
then all the people watching as you
continue to build up the momentum behind
it well some of them will say hey that's
really cool I love how I love what she
did I love I love this random person
I've never heard of her before but I'm
maybe she's the coach for me
I love that thank you and it's just the
most fun you know it's like you feel
like it matters
because 1400 people is a lot of people
but it it's hard to it doesn't feel
tangible
right like that's a small town you got
14 you had an entire town of people who
are following you but it's hard to feel
tangible but when you see one person and
you see her eyes like oh my gosh that
you're so right Randa and your little
tweak then sets him on a different path
because you gave them gave her the
answer
um it makes you feel like what you're
doing really matters right well and
that's like that's the point is to be
able to witness and listen to someone
and acknowledge where they're at and
validate where they're at and then be
able to assist them in tools that I've
learned and tools that I'm certified in
like that's that's the whole point
yeah so you already have enough people
who are following you
you just video message them one by one
and say hey I'm starting a new show this
is what I did at the beginning when I
started my show I was on an airplane
from LA to Toronto and I messaged people
one by one to say do you want to be my
my guest I'm going to start a new show I
went live every day I did it in Toronto
so they had to be in we did it an
Instagram live but they were sitting
next to me oh cool I had a smaller pool
of people to pull from because it had to
be local where doing this could be
anywhere in the world
um and I booked the first five people
to do my show for the first week
and built momentum it's scary
but worth it and if it feels right then
the best thing you can do is go like for
momentum you know immediate action like
right after this go book your first
person for tomorrow and launch a show
um I'll tell you because when I had the
idea on the airplane from LA to Toronto
and I was 100 like this is going to be
so much fun I can't wait to do this and
then
come day to day that was a Friday night
was flying back to Toronto and I was
going to start my show on Monday
on Monday morning I show up and like I
don't want to do the show zero zero
percent I'm too busy I don't have time
for this what if I don't know how to
answer their question what if I can't
help all of like the insecurities and
doubts right 100 on Friday night turned
to zero percent on Monday morning and it
was only because I had booked the first
people that I had to I'm not gonna not
show up like somebody's in my studio I
had to go there and meet them right so
I'm more likely to actually follow
through yeah
so yeah it's like it feels right then
it's booking your first people
and asking if they want to do the show
I feel like you're reading my mind
because I'll I'm asking questions in my
mind and then you're automatically
answering them well that's and you know
it's the right path yeah and so it's
really as easy as right after this you
spend an hour
sending messages to people on Instagram
and I like a quick video message and
just 10 seconds you know hey Susan
thanks for following me I'm starting a
new show of coaching women through their
relationships or is it just women who
coach guys too no men too cool you know
but obviously you you know if it's Susan
you're saying women if it's Bill you're
seeing it anyways but you know hey Bill
I'm certain thank you so much for
following starting a new show uh helping
people through the relationships if you
have any issues and you'd like me to
coach you one-on-one I'm starting a new
show next next week if you want to be my
first guest let me know
and then again hey Susan I like I even
do it walking I like getting fresh air
and like walking and get a Vibe so I'm
walking down the street while I'm doing
it but um yeah just like 10 second
videos at a time to the people who
follow you and at worst it's a it's a
touch point to thank them for following
you right and nobody sends personal
messages like that
yeah yeah I like that
I like being in people's space like that
with a video that's so much more
personable
than a text
yeah and and fun and and they'll see it
and and even if some people will say yes
like if you send five messages you may
not get somebody to say yes right so we
got it we gotta send more you know like
let's put 50 on our list of 1400 let's
send 50 messages you'll get some people
but even for the ones who don't say yes
you're you're building a relationship
somebody might write back and say how
much they love your content or looking
forward to your book or all of these
things that are built it's crazy how
much a 10 second video message impacts
somebody because nobody's reaching out
to their followers and just thanking
them
yeah so it's something I do every
morning I'll go for I call it a believe
walk I go through my believe walk and uh
and I'll just I'll just randomly pick
people who follow me and send personal
messages and just I love that
that's awesome yeah and it feels good
it's like it's not just a good strategy
it's a good strategy but it also feels
good that it's like these are 1400 real
people you know maybe some of them are
Bots you know maybe there's 100 bots so
it's like 1300 like but they're real
people those are real people who've got
goals and dreams and aspirations and
relationship problems and all of these
things and they're following you because
you posted something that touched their
heart in some way and so just being able
to say thank you and reach out
um will lead to all sorts of crazy good
things but especially booking you know
people for your show
thank you thank you
like that's an easy one that's a
no-brainer and then you can clip the
content and do like you know take
highlight moments and reuse them or take
one liners and put them up on your
channel
um speaking should be you speaking
yeah so like you're ideally it's with
some at least it looks like in front of
some kind of crowd yeah in high schools
or universities or again YMCAs like I
got started the YMCA and three people
came to my first event
but it doesn't matter like you go and
you serve you help those three people
you know action is action yeah
um and then the other one is what the
book or the courses
um yeah yeah digital courses
so another great thing to do is you have
somebody
um like is the course already ready to
sell or you're working on it yeah yeah
and are like you already made some sales
on the Internet or you're working on it
well I have made one sale perfect this
is great the first sale is the hardest
sale you know as long as it's not to
your husband or your mom or something
but no that's like that's the great
start and what you can do is
um
for the for the early people who buy the
course offer the do an Instagram live
with them too
okay
do you know you know actually let's not
say her name but like you know let's
let's say her name was Jill right who
bought your first course cool you reach
out to jail and say Hey Jill thank you
so much for buying my course I hope it's
being valuable for you
um do you want to do a bonus Instagram
live with me where we whatever questions
you've got whatever you want to talk
about I'm here to serve and hopefully
your questions can also serve the
audience watching too
um again maybe Jill is super introverted
or shy and doesn't want to come on
camera but like at the very worst case
you're building you're saying thank you
and she's gonna feel recognized which is
always great but if she says yes then
she's going to come on your Instagram
live you're going to go and get your
content together and then what's she
gonna say she's gonna say oh I just
bought your course it's amazing thank
you so much now you're talking about the
course without talking about the course
yeah so now anybody watching can learn
about oh she's got a course what's the
course all about
right so anybody knew who's getting into
the course you can offer it doesn't
scale incredibly well right like you
can't do it for everybody if you're
gonna sell we're going to sell a million
of these courses right so so Ryan is not
going to do a million IG lives but for
the first people come in and it could
still be part of you know if you had
like once a week coaching from your
followers and then once a week coaching
from people who bought the course as you
start to make more sales
um even once a week coaching people who
bought the book do you have any books
for sale yet or not yet they're all in
different yeah cool yeah they they're
all slated for uh September
okay well we're not that far away like
you can even do pre-orders right you
already have the book title do you have
a cover you're working on the cover
I have a cover yeah cool so you have a
title you have a cover
um you could do pre-orders that if
somebody buys 10 copies of the book they
also get an Instagram live with you
or 100 copies or a thousand copies or
whatever
um and then we start
we start talking about the book right
even though the book's not ready yet
until September she bought she bought 10
copies and she so she gets the IG live
with you and then she's gonna come on
and say I'm so excited for your book it
comes out in September right I can't
wait to get copy so now we're talking
about the book without talking about the
book and still serving her to help her
or him with you know whatever issues
they've got going on so it's just fun
like it helps promote the thing that
you're trying to promote and it doesn't
mean stop doing I'm not I'm not super
deep on your content and like what
you've been posting and frequency but
um are you how like what's your Cadence
how often are you actually posting
content right now
um I'm probably
two or three times a week okay
and does that feel good does that feel a
lot does that feel
it feels like not enough one of those I
have a podcast so one is a podcast every
week
um I'm trying to ramp that up and do
reels and and add more content that way
um so I feel like I feel like three to
four would be a manageable number for me
a good number and what do you talk about
on the podcast or what's the format
um gosh I have my husband on there
um
it's like whatever spiritual message
downloads to my brain it's it's not
pigeonhole to one thing I love it that's
great
so you have the podcast and then it
really just depends on the on the
Cadence and how much
you want to put in and how much it
builds you versus drains you
um this is an example
this builds me like today's my mentoring
day all I'm doing is mentoring the
people on my team
we've got 40 people on the team and it's
just all day like 25 minutes on five
minute break 25 minutes on five minute
break like into the next person next
yeah but then but then like two o'clock
Eastern I break to do this because it it
doesn't I'm Gonna Leave This with more
energy than I came in you're giving me
energy you're not taking that energy and
that's most of the time like this I
guess is sometimes you have somebody
that's not as great but for the most
part like I leave more connected to the
mission of why I do what I do than less
um and it's because of having somebody
on with you who
oh you feel like you helped like if you
feel like you served today and not just
at home with the computer it makes you
know a big difference
so
the Cadence is up to you obviously but
if you had a regular series around
coaching people who are following you
you know a regular series around people
who bought the book or pre-ordered the
book a regular series around people who
bought the course
that could be you know three four five
Instagram lives a week
it could even just be a regular show
that you go live with and start taking
questions from people that's what I do
like it just uh two o'clock Eastern
we're going live either Instagram or in
one of my other communities two o'clock
Eastern we go live and I just set that
in my schedule for half an hour and it's
like right in the middle of the day and
it really works for me for my flow and
then it doesn't feel like work or I have
to make content or I'm struggling with
like what do I come up with next right
as you're helping somebody you're gonna
say something genius hopefully in some
in in this I said something genius but
then we can cut and turn into a reel or
turn into something else right yeah uh
hopefully you know hopefully when you're
helping somebody you say you're going to
say a lot more genius things that then
turns into maybe 10 reels that you can
use for your content
I most importantly doesn't feel like
work and it doesn't feel like you're not
doing enough because you have your
regular show coming out that's actually
helping people
I love that okay I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do 50 reach outs today
and I'm gonna call the YMCA
I love it there you go yeah like the
speaking is harder because you know you
you have to do more Outreach and you not
everybody's gonna say yes and just make
sure you're filming it you know that we
see you on stage but YMC is a great
school assemblies are great
um school yeah I mean now school might
be hard but I don't know if summer
school is still doing like assemblies
and stuff but libraries awesome any
Community groups clubs meetups like
anything where you can basically be on
any kind of stage and then film it
like oh she's a speaker
you know so even you had just won a
month of those
um at the very early stage of my career
I did it uh there was a group called
Enterprise Toronto that's in my city
that supports entrepreneurs and I would
speak there
for like 50 bucks for an hour and a half
and there'd be 12 people in there or
something you know yeah
um I did it more just to serve and to
help the community I wish I had content
like now I would do it for free just to
get content so that I have something for
my my Instagram and YouTube channels
um but there's a lot of different
Community like are you in a decent sized
city
yeah I'm in the Phoenix metropolitan
area
um yeah I mean Phoenix is huge so many
so many different groups so many
different clubs so many different
organizations
um
that they would love to have a speaker
and you just don't be attached to oh I
need to have a thousand people in the
room you know right 10 people show up
you're there to serve and film the
content so that you have something that
you could put up
um on your channels and I think it's
also great just to show the journey you
know just to here's where I started
everybody I didn't start
once you're on stage and you know
Oprah's introducing you and you know
you're doing your duet with Garth Brooks
or you know whatever whatever it is
that's happening uh you get to show like
the early starts and the humble
beginnings and the early stage work that
you did and that was still it was still
just about helping people more than
about I need to have you know a thousand
people or ten thousand people in their
own yeah you and Karen in the front row
of course you'll be we'll be singing
along
cool well I know we don't have uh we're
actually a little bit over but let's
let's talk quickly about your book what
what you've got coming up
um
healing through broken relationships
like maybe a just a quick overview or
some advice you've got so we can let my
audience know about it
um okay if I could tell everybody one
thing
about these books and I'm gonna I'm
actually gonna put them all together
it's that wherever you put your
attention in your relationships
and how much you put in is what you're
going to get out
so my husband and I were married 12
years we had four kids didn't put a lot
of time and attention got divorced while
I was married with our fifth
got remarried three years later and now
we put in so much time and effort into
this relationship
that it may not work out it may not you
never know what life's gonna bring but
because we put so much time and effort
our relationship is so sweet and I find
that in every relationship what you put
in is what you'll get out so wherever
you are in your relationships
um
the Brokenness is a gift because it
opens you up for healing in other areas
of your life and it shows you what you
need to work on
I love it sprinkling the little tidbits
in there it's great well everybody go
check out Randa appreciate you book
comes out in September
September yep September go check it out
Rhonda thank you for doing a hard thing
is it was how hard was this was it was
it as scary as you thought no you're
amazing you're amazing I appreciate you
coming on I'm looking forward to more of
your content coming up and uh good luck
on your new coaching show to see me
coach another entrepreneur one on one
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there it's not that we
hate people it's that we hate shallow
conversations yeah we want something
that's deep and meaningful I forgot how
I was going to open up my speech serving
others is hardwired into US it makes you
feel good how do you find your purpose